nos dicen que esta es la gráfica de la
función f muy bien la función que se
define como jefe x es igual a efe de 2x
cuál es la gráfica deje pausa este vídeo
y trata de resolverlo por tu cuenta muy
bien ahora vamos a trabajar en esto y la
forma en que lo abordaré será mediante
una tabla y tendré una columna para x y
luego tendré una columna para gx y por
supuesto jefe x es igual a efe de 2x así
que cuando x es déjenme ver cuando x es
igual a podría elegir un punto como x
igual a 0
entonces g de 0 será efe de 2 x 0 sera
efe de 2 x 0 que todavía es f de 0 y que
va a ser igual a un poco más de 4
entonces es igual a efe de 0 ambos van a
tener la misma intersección en ye pero
van a suceder cosas interesantes cuanto
más lejos lleguemos del eje x o en tanto
nuestra x aumente en cualquier dirección
o cuando nuestra x se hace más grande en
cualquier dirección desde
así que pensemos en lo que va a pasar en
x igual a 2 cuando x es igual a 2 g de 2
va a ser igual a efe de 2 por 2 que es
igual a efe de 4 y sabemos cuánto sf de
efe de 4 es igual a 0 entonces g de 2 es
igual a efe de 4 que es igual a 0
fíjense que el punto correspondiente
tiene una especie de comprimido o
aplastado en dirección horizontal de
modo que ves lo que está pasando al
menos en este lado de la gráfica todo
está sucediendo un poco más rápido lo
que sea que sucede en cierta equis ahora
está sucediendo a la mitad de esa equis
entonces este lado de la gráfica se verá
como algo así todo sucede al doble de
rápido y que pasa cuando vas en la
dirección negativa bueno piensa en
cuánto es gd menos 2 g de menos 2 es
igual a efe de 2 x menos 2 que es igual
a efe de menos 4 que vemos que también
es igual a 0
entonces g de menos 2 es
y podrías estar pensando por qué
elegiste 22 bueno la intuición nos dice
que las cosas se van a comprimir las
cosas están sucediendo al doble de
rápido así que todo lo que estaba
sucediendo en x igual a 4 ahora va a
suceder en x igualados lo que sea que
esté sucediendo en x igual a menos 4
ahora va a suceder en x igual a menos 2
y vi que teníamos puntos muy claros en x
igual a menos 4 y x igual a 4 ene efe
así que tomé la mitad de eso para elegir
mis valores de x que puse aquí y
entonces como se va a ver nuestra
gráfica se verá más o menos así va a
aparecer que ha sido aplastada por la
derecha y por la izquierda hagamos otro
ejemplo
ahora no solo nos han dado la gráfica de
f nos han dado una expresión cual es la
gráfica de eje x que es igual a esto que
tenemos aquí pausa este vídeo e intenta
resolverlo muy bien la clave es
descubrir la relación entre fx y gx y
podemos ver que la principal diferencia
es que en el lugar de la x que tenemos
en fx acá tenemos x sobre 2 entonces en
todas partes donde había una equis han
sido reemplazadas por x sobre 2 otra
forma de pensar en esto es que x es
igual a efe x sobre 2 otra forma de
pensar al respecto es que ge x es igual
a efe de un medio de x y luego podemos
hacer un ejercicio similar nos han dado
algunos puntos interesantes
el punto x igualados el punto de x igual
a 4 y el punto x igual a 6 pensemos en
esto la última vez cuando gm x será
igual a 12 x las cosas ocurrían al doble
de rápido ahora las cosas van a pasar a
la mitad de rápido
así que dejen de poner una pequeña tabla
aquí los valores de x que me interesan
son los que si tomo la mitad de ellos
entonces voy a obtener uno de estos
puntos así que déjenme escribir esto un
medio de x y luego puedo pensar cuánto
es gd x que es igual a efe de un medio
de x entonces quiero que un medio de x
sea veamos podría ser 2 4 y 6 2 4 y 6 y
porque los elegí de nuevo bueno es muy
claro qué valores toma f en esos puntos
y así si un medio de x es igual a 2
entonces x es igual a 4 si un medio de x
es igual a 4
entonces x es igual a 8 y si x es igual
a 12 entonces un medio de x es igual a 6
y así podríamos decir que g de 4 es
igual a efe de 2 que es igual a 0 por
eso elegí 2 4 y 6
es muy fácil evaluar efe de 2 efe de 4 y
efe de 6 nos dieron esos puntos muy
claramente entonces g de 8 va a ser
igual a efe
de 8 o efe de 4 que es igual a menos 4 y
luego g de 12 es igual a efe de 6 que es
la mitad de 12 que es igual a cero otra
vez y podríamos trazar estos puntos y
tener una idea general de la forma de la
gráfica así que veamos que de 4 es igual
a 0 g de 8 es igual a menos 4 justo aquí
y luego g de 12 es igual a cero otra vez
así que todo se ha estirado ahí lo
tienes se ha extendido al menos en la
dirección horizontal es una forma de
pensar en eso en dirección horizontal y
puedes ver que este punto en f
corresponde a este punto y que está dos
veces más lejos del origen porque todo
está creciendo a la mitad de rápido
pones una equis tomas la mitad y luego
lo pones en efe y luego este punto justo
aquí corresponde a este punto en lugar
de estar en cuatro este vértice ahora
está en 8 y por último pero no menos
importante este punto justo aquí
corresponde a este punto en lugar de
ocurrir en x igual a 6
ocurriendo en x 12 todo se está
estirando hagamos un ejemplo más
fx es igual a todo esto debemos tener
cuidado hay una raíz cúbica por aquí y g
es una versión escalada horizontalmente
df las funciones están graficadas donde
f es continua y que es punteada cuál es
la ecuación deje pausa este vídeo y
trata de resolverlo muy bien hagamos
esto juntos nos han dado algunos puntos
que parecen corresponder entre sí para
ir de efe ag parece que estos puntos
correspondientes han sido apretados más
cerca del origen y lo que podemos ver es
que efe de -3 parece ser igual a gd
menos uno y f de seis parece ser igual a
g de 2
g de 2 otra forma de pensar en esto es
que cualquier x que pongas en g parece
que va a ser equivalente a 3 por la
equis que pongas en f así que gm x es
igual a efe de 3x de modo que si
queremos saber la ecuación de g
sólo evaluamos efe de 3x entonces
efe de 3x será igual a voy a poner un
signo igual como éste efe de 3x será
igual a menos 3 por la raíz cúbica de en
lugar de una x pondré 3x justo aquí 13 x
+ 2 y luego tenemos más 1 y eso es todo
gd x es igual a esto es igual a efe de
3x que es esto sustituimos esta x con 3x
y hemos terminado